In this section, we will continue going over the steps for using the custom body workflow.
We will first initialize the script and load everything into memory.
And then we will execute step one and step two.
So let's go over initializing the script first.
The steps to initialize the script are to first ensure you have pasted the entire API
interface script into the script editor.
Then select the script from line 1 to 72 and execute it.
To set the DNA calibration path and paths for the working folder, select line 75 to
105 and execute that.
Let's jump into Maya and go through this.
Inside of Maya, we will begin by initializing the script.
I'm going to scroll down here, past all this code and references to other scripts, and
I'm going to select everything from line 72 all the way up to 1 and then we'll execute
this to load this into memory.
Now I want to set the paths to the directories.
So I will select everything from line 75 to 106 and execute this.
We can now start executing each step.
Let's begin with step one, which will position and scale the head rig for integration.
Over here, I will select the first portion of step one from line 114 to 126 and execute
it.
Once this is finished loading, over here, this will load the body combined rig into
the scene.
It has taken a copy of the head LOD zero from the MetaHumanDNA head mesh over here and named
it position and scale mesh.
If we had not used the previous DNA calibration script, the mesh would be much smaller and
would probably be somewhere over here.
For this portion of step one, we would select the position and scale mesh and just as we
had done with the locator, we would manually position and scale it.
The next step is to run the second part of step one.
Select this section over here from line 133 to 146 and execute it.
This will bake the position and scale to a new MetaHumanDNA file named updatedScale,
which will be added to the output folder in the DNA files folder.
It will then load the updatedScaleDNA with the body rig into a new scene.
Now that it is loaded, if I select the head group from this new DNA file, on the right
over here, if we had made adjustments, we will see that there would be no transform values
as those have been baked into the DNA.
Another thing this command will do is it will match the head mesh and skeleton position
with the body skeleton position.
Now before we move on to step two, let's do a quick review of what we just covered.
Step one will position and scale the head rig for integration.
Select the first portion of step one from line 113 to 126 and run it.
This will load the MetaHumanDNA head meshes and joints and the body rig Maya file into
a new scene.
A copy of the LOD0 head geometry named position and scale mesh will appear.
Since the atomic savage character has already been scaled and positioned from the previous
workflow, the images on the right demonstrate what the unmodified version of the atomic
savage DNA head mesh would look like.
From here we would need to position and scale the head.
Using the position and scale mesh, we would manually position and scale the head, as is
shown in the images on the bottom right.
This is similar to how we used the locator in the previous workflow, with the values
being almost the same.
Once we are happy with the scale and position, we can run the second portion of step one
from line 133 to 137.
This portion of the script will bake the position and scale to a new DNA file named
updated scale.
We can then review the new DNA file by running the last portion of step one to load the DNA.
Once we run the last portion of step one from line 143 to 146, this will load the updated
scale DNA file and the body rig into a new scene.
What we can see in the images on the bottom right is that the mesh and joint positioning
of the new DNA matches the body rig position.
Again, this is very similar to the previous workflow we went over, where it scales and
translates the rig.
Now let's take a look at step two before we jump back into Maya.
For step two, if we were using the original atomic savage metahuman DNA file, for the
first portion of this step, we would create a new neutral mesh using the updated scale
DNA file in order to blend the neck area with the body.
The images on this slide demonstrate what this process would look like if we were to
use the original atomic savage DNA file.
The first and second image show what the neck seam would look like after step one, and the
third image shows what the neck seam would look like after we have authored a new neutral
mesh.
Using the LOD0 head mesh from the updated scale DNA file, we would blend the neck vertex
positions from the body with the neck area, and then export this as an obj file.
We would then place it in the assets folder.
If using your own character, let's go over the steps for creating the new neutral mesh.
To create a new neutral mesh with the updated neck seam, in a new Maya scene, use the DNA
viewer run in Maya script to load the updated scale DNA file.
For the meshes option, assemble only the head LOD0 mesh and leave everything else unchecked,
as shown in the image on the bottom left.
From there, take the head LOD0 mesh and manually fit the neck geometry in order to integrate
it with the body while respecting the edges and loops.
Once the head mesh is properly fitted to the body, export that as an obj file and add
the new head mesh to the assets folder.
Back in Maya after the new neutral mesh has been created and placed in the assets folder,
next we want to ensure that the path for the new neutral mesh obj file is correct on line
156.
From there, select everything from line 153 to 175 and execute it.
This will update the DNA using the new neutral mesh obj file and then match the core joints
of the spine, neck, and shoulders to the body rig.
It will then load a new Maya scene so that we can inspect it.
Now that this is finished loading, I am going to go into top view and I'm going to show
the skeleton.
I will select the head group so that we can see the skeleton and then select the body.
And if we inspect the skeletons, we will see that the head joints are now aligned with
the body, which is exactly what we wanted.
Now let's do a quick review of step 2 before moving on.
For step 2, once the new neutral mesh has been authored, using the updated scale DNA
and then add it to the assets folder, make sure that the path to the new neutral mesh
has been set correctly and then select everything from line 153 to 175 and execute it.
This will update the DNA using the new neutral mesh obj file and the core joints of the spine,
neck, and shoulders will match the body rig.
With the head joints aligned with the body joints, as demonstrated in the images on the
right, we can then proceed to step 3.
Now that's it for this section.
In the next section, we will continue going through the rest of the steps for the custom
body workflow.